Hey it's me Destin, welcome back to Smarter Every Day.
I have built a potato gun out of clear pipe
which is amazing because you can see what's going on
on the inside of the potato gun.
Today's experiment is going to be pretty fun.
Please excuse my scratchy voice but this is my only day off of work.
This is my buddy. What are you going to do to help me?
Uhmm, I'm going to trigger the high speed camera.
Destin: Trigger the high speed camera. That's right.
This is the high speed camera we are going to use
to film at about 3000 fps.
This is going to be a pretty big explosion so you are going to need that.
We've got our potato ammunition, isobutane propellant (hairspray), watermelon and large squash.
We're going to put a squash up here and we are going to hit it with a potato
and see how much force we can transfer to that thing. You ready? Should be fun, let's give it a shot.
Okay so the important thing when are putting a potato in a potato gun is you want a seal  all the way around the potato.
There is a fancy word for that. It is called obturation.
If you can get a complete obturation seal on the obturator you can get more compression and more velocity.
So let's see how many Mississippi's we are going to put in here...
3, 2, 1
Alright let's see. Let's see if it worked.
Broke just a little bit but we can do better than that can't we? Alright let's do it again!
Okay that white part all the way around that's touching the barrel on the potato that's called the what?
Obturator. And what does the obturator do?
It makes the air not go past the bullet.
Destin: That's right. It makes the explosion not go past the bullet.
Ohhh that was a weak one wasn't it?
We broke the squash.
Destin: Did we?
I think gravity did that more than the potato don't you?
Let's go look at the high speed but I think the potato is breaking when it hits the squash
so we might have to make a stronger potato on the front.
Okay the potato is just shattering on impact. So clearly we need to fortify our potato.
So I'm going to drill a hole in it here and put some metal on the front and see what that does.
3, 2, 1
I think that worked...
Okay so the potato kept breaking, right?
So we are going to use this. But it is made in a plastic case,
so why can we use this in the barrel?
Because it has the obturator.
That's right. Good for you that's a big word for a little boy im proud of you.
Okay let's go get it set up.
You hear that seal? It's really good.
It's really hard to do it because it's a really good seal.
3, 2, 1
Are you ready? 3, 2, 1, Go!
Okay one quick thing I wanted to point out about the potato gun,
it has to do with pressure, volume, and velocity.
As the propellant ignites and pressure causes the potato to move down the barrel,
when it does this the volume behind the potato expands.
As the volume increases, if the burn rate doesn't keep up, sometimes the pressure can start to decrease.
Different types of potato gun propellant  burn at different rates. Depending on the length of the barrel,
if the volume expands to much, the pressure inside the chamber can actually dip below atmospheric pressure.
The pressure can dip so low in fact that it can condense water vapor out of the air.
I'm not 100% sure that's what is happening in this next clip but it's still awesome. Check it out.
That is what you call backyard ballastics.
I hope you enjoy this episode of Smarter Everyday. It was brought to you buy Audible.com.
Before I tell you about the book I've been listening to I'm going to tell you about the next episode
which is ridiculous. It's the same combustion chamber, transparent, at night, in slow motion,
but I propagate that flame by initiating it at different points inside the combustion chamber.
When I saw the slow-mo I just giggled like a lot. It's really a blast.
That was bad, I'm so sorry. Anyway, if you want to see that episode go click that potato right over there.
I think you will really enjoy it. Back to the sponsor.
Audible.com sponsors Smarter Everyday and this is really easy to sell for me, this is not a challenge
because Audible is my happy place. When I get on an airplane my favorite thing to do is to play a game on my phone
and listen to an audio book. recently I'm listening to a Hitchhicker's Guide to the Galaxy the Restaurant at the End of the Universe.
I really enjoy it. I've done this for years. I've listened to audio books on Audible.com well before they decided
to start sponsoring Smarter Everyday. I listen to a bunch of books these are the ones I have physical copies of, whatever.
It's you getting smarter. This is what you call a soft sell. I don't have to convince you, you're smart people,
you know why going to audible.com/smarter would help Smarter Every Day. You also know that listening to
audio books is smart. Anyway, that's it. There is plenty of stuff to click if you are interested in doing that.
If you want to go click that potato and go giggle with me, feel free to do that. I'm Destin and you're getting smarter every day. Have a good one.
What happen's if I start the ignition of the potato gun from the back?
What happens if I start from the middle?
(laughing)